hello everyone and welcome to a truly
incredible correspondence game from 1933
between the Estonian Powerhouse Paul
quieresa and a gentleman named idra
verbat or verbach or fernaha uh it's not
um known what the exact identity of the
gentleman is that's why I'm wearing a
hoodie and I'm hoping you guys are as
well but Edward winter the legendary
historian says that it is most likely
the second one uh verbach as his
Estonian and that is an an Estonian uh
last name uh so that being said let's
check it out and see this incredible
game by by the then uh 17 year old maybe
he was even 16 16 17 Euro Paul quieres
because even the year isn't um the same
depending on where you check uh you know
somewhere it's published as 1932
somewhere 1933 somewhere 1934. so it's
um you know could be could be Ireland
it's a correspondence game so you know
we have no idea basically but the moves
are what's important here the game
features a very exciting opening
features a beautiful double bishop
checkmate so let's check it out uh
Powell uh with the white pieces opens
with Pawn to D4 we have pointed D5 and
now something we don't see very often on
the on this channel or pretty much
anywhere Ponte E4 this is the black mark
Gambit that if black accepts y can
transpose into the blackmar edemer
Gambit but here black doesn't black just
plays Pawn to E6 and from a really weird
opening we end up with a normal uh
French defense but Karis doesn't want to
play the the normal French defense and
he plays Bishop to E3 uh this is the
alapin Gambit against the French defense
where you Gambit the E4 pawn and black
will very happily defend it with F5 and
that's exactly what happens here here
Verma goes for D captures on e4 Knight
the D2 now going after the pawn and pawn
to F5 if you have a problem uh playing
against the French Maybe Blitz game
throwing bullet games you can try this
and you know good things might happen
and Here pawn to F3 here Kerris
challenges the uh the strong Center
giving up
uh the the that pawn already just not
winning it back we have captures
captures 92 F6 and Bishop to D3 for the
price of that one Pawn uh Karis is
getting some very nice development in
and here we have Pawn to C5 and it is
now as of move seven that this position
has never been reached again so here uh
Paul uh castles uh we have C capture
Sunday for Knight cap percent D4 and
this is where the magic happens here
black could continue with uh a couple of
very nice moves like Knight to C6 just
developing is perfectly fine Knight to
G4 going after the bishop is perfectly
fine uh but here Ponte Ponte F4 was
played which makes a lot of sense
because
um uh if Bishop captures Queen captures
and D4 comes with check you lose a
knight and if you capture with the Rook
then the problem is E5 will attack The
Rook end the Knight but there's an even
bigger problem than white just
blundering a piece here uh black skin is
still on E8 and the bishop hasn't been
developed so you still need at least two
the castle and Karis does not need a you
know a second invitation he just goes
for Rook captures on F4 Ponte E5 and now
uh there are so many cool ways to win
this game it's absolutely incredible uh
Karis goes for Bishop to B5 with check
which is which is nice but I will also
show Rook captures an F6 now look at
this if you capture with the G Pawn then
of course Queen to H5 with track King to
A7 and Bishop C4 uh already you can see
that this is uh quite losing for black
if Queen to E8 now you're gonna play
Queen to F3 and once e captures and D4
is played Bishop captures and now what
um uh what do you do to stop Rook D1 you
have to start running away with the King
but now Queen captures connects nicely
with the Rook uh and I mean black has
zero development then you're gonna win
material back so this is completely lost
but it's interesting what happens if
Queen captures an F6 probably why uh
Karis decided to go for that Bishop to
B5 line but still unite the E4 check
Knight E4 attacks the queen look at this
funny formation here Queen G6 and not
Knight to B5 this is the star move uh
because now there's no defense uh how do
you stop this a knight to C7 check is
coming Knight the D6 check is coming
black will lose the queen and if you try
to save the queen with something like
Queen to C6 the to Parry both threats
then comes Queen to H5 check G6 and
queen captures and E5 again completely
shattering Black's defenses if Bishop T6
you're just gonna capture on h8 and
there's nothing black can do here
there's no move you can play so that's
why after E5 or not that's why uh
probably because uh he didn't spot that
night to to B5 move right away he played
Bishop to B5 with check King the F7
because now if Bishop to D7 probably now
uh Karis wanted to play uh Rook captures
and F6 because it's pretty similar but
now let's say Bishop captures on B5
Queen to H5 trick G6 Queen captures an
E5 with check Bishop to E7 and now
Knight to E4 and again how do you
survive this with Black Knights the C6
attacks the queen but now even The Rook
captures on C6 bishop captress and C6
Knight to F6 with check you have to go
back to F7 uh so King to F7 Queen to E6
check King to G7 and now a spectacular
Checkmate Knight the H5 with check you
either go to f8 and then Bishop to H6
check or you capture and then Bishop to
H6 is a beautiful checkmate
uh so that's why after Bishop to B5
check you don't see Bishop to D7 here uh
verbach goes for King to F7 but this
only allows Keras to finish in and even
um even uh more spectacular style Queen
to H5 with check Pawn to G6 and now
Bishop the C4 with check we have King to
G7 and now again there are many ways to
end the game but there is one that ends
the game in three moves so feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
forced mate in three uh for Karis while
I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always looking
for coolest ways to sacrifice your queen
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Queen to H6 with
check leaving black with only one option
as the bishop covers F7 and G8 you have
to capture the queen and now again many
moves to win here but the cleanest one
is Rook the H5 with a double a rook dh4
with a double check from the rook and
the bishop only move for the king is to
go back but now Bishop to H6 is
Checkmate and there there you have it a
beautiful double bishop checkmate and uh
what what a game by by the legendary pal
Karis against uh uh against the
gentleman who who could be named either
verbat verb
but what's even more amazing is that
this was a correspondence game and in
those days you know you you had no idea
who you were playing against you you
know you you could be playing against
one opponent you could be playing
against his entire family like his
entire Workforce his entire uh but still
you you play such a game and the well it
would be a shame if it weren't published
but this one was saved and now we can
again enjoy it because it's uh I mean
okay there are a lot of lines here but
basically after this F4 move here uh
it's just amazing that uh Kerris looks
uh you know he he doesn't just back off
he goes for Rook captures on F4 and then
it's just you know very very quick
Checkmate even though there's like a
whole sea of other lines
um before we actually reach this uh so
yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it another brilliant see by the
legendary Paul Karis uh I would like to
thank Carlos Roddy David Kimura Fred
Ackerman randompile.net and Glenn Beaton
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the uh to
check off on your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the Chess
World uh thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day